plus de 400 experts ont travaillé durant
trois ans produire la plus grande étude
jamais réalisée sur la biodiversité 132
pays non endosser ils sont tous d'accord
sur un point les plus petites créatures
ou plus énormes des savanes de l'afrique
aux régions polaires la nature se fait
vampiriser d'un bout à l'autre de la
planète ont constaté les chercheurs
résultats 75% du milieu terrestre est
dégradée 66% du milieu marin et jusqu'à
un million des 8 millions d'espèces
animales et végétales connue pourrait
disparaître
l'extinction à laquelle on assiste en ce
moment la direction les rythmes de
disparition des espèces
et on parle de dizaines de fois voire
centaines de fois plus rapides que ce
qui serait le taux naturel
la biodiversité est attaqué de toutes
parts disent les experts
changement climatique espèces invasives
pollution industrielle surexploitation
des ressources
à titre d'exemple on récolte 45% plus de
bois qu'en 1970 et durant la même
période la production agricole a triplé
alors que le rendement des sols lui est
en baisse constante à jouy le 's&p' a
devancé dans son ensemble c'est la
croissance économique à tout prix qui
est montré du doigt pour expliquer le
déclin constant et rapide de la
biodiversité la protection de la
biodiversité à implique nécessairement
qu'on mette des limites à notre
développement économique à l'utilisation
qu'on fait des ressources et on n'a
jamais réussi à le faire pour des
raisons politiques oui mais surtout pour
des raisons économiques notre système
économique carbure à l'utilisation des
ressources
les auteurs du rapport insiste lui même
qui n'est quand même pas la veille de la
sixième grande extinction des espèces
nous rappelle que le premier sommet sur
la biodiversité a eu lieu à rio en 1992
ic depuis la situation n'a fait
qu'empirer ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal